- Let's get beautiful.
(pop music playing)
- For the Try Guys to
properly get immersed
into Korean culture, we're
going to be attending KCON,
North America's largest K-pop
convention and music festival.
- All right, Sunny, K-pop's makeup
takes between three and six hours,
we got 20 minutes.
- Yeah, okay.
- Make me beautiful.
I'm going to transform you guys
into four K-pop groups,
Girl's Generation,
2NE1, 4Minute, and f(x).
- I wear polo shirts all the time.
I've never changed this haircut.
I'm excited.
- I like getting makeup put on.
It's sort of like a mini face massage.
I think it's kind of relaxing.
- I think I look a little more Korean
than the other Try Guys.
- [Try Guy] That's racist.
- I've been saying for years
that I'm the prettiest Try Guy.
Today's my chance to prove it.
- (laughs)
- I've been saying it for years.
- The Korean notion of beauty,
I think is a little different
than, say, what we have here in the West.
Beauty is not something
that you're born with,
it's something that you cultivate.
- Are you making me paler?
That's not possible.
- What's an interesting challenge for us
is that I have a monolid,
which means that I don't have the crease,
so eye makeup is completely different.
- You were born with certain
face, certain body type,
but the notion is that
you can always improve it.
- You're really jamming it in there, huh?
- I get so relaxed when
I get makeup put on.
I'm a canvas.
- K-pop stars do this for hours?
It hurts my eyes so much.
- When I was growing up in high school,
like no one liked Korean stuff.
No one knew about K-pop.
- Do they have American Con in Korea?
- Beauty is a process.
Not everyone's born as beautiful as me,
so you just, you have to work at it.
- If you're paying enough attention
and using the right products
or going to the right hair salon,
you can get the right look.
- Without all my imperfections,
I look beautiful.
- I've always said I got little eyes,
but I'm proud of them.
So all you small-eyed Asians out there,
don't let anyone tell you
that you aren't pretty
because you don't got
big ol' eyes like Keith.
- ♫ Go on and paint my face.
♫ Make me look like another race.
(laughs)
- I wonder if my wife
does makeup like this.
You're right, she doesn't.
- The reason Korean society
is so beauty-conscious or body-conscious
is not because people are superficial,
but I think it's because it's
a really competitive society.
- K-pop.
- How much would I have to pay you
to sabotage Eugene's makeup?
- You gave me the CL
signature beauty mark!
- I don't know what
everybody's freaking out about.
It's just a little paint
on your face, girl.
- (screams) No!
I thought we were finishing up.
- On a scale of 1 to 10,
how bad do you want to bang me right now?
30? (laughs)
- Here we go.
Oh, yeah!
I just look like, I kind
of look like my grandma.
- Whoa! Okay!
I look just sensual, passionate,
like Cruella de Vil.
- What a good job you did!
Look how cute I am!
I'm two different people!
Keith and Kevin.
- Yeah!
That mole. (laughs)
If I just cover my face like
this, that is CL's eyes.
that is CL's eyes.
You did a great job.
Thank you so much, Sunny,
for transforming us into K-pop stars.
We have to go to a photo shoot now.
- I am here with the beautiful Irene Kim.
- You are a model.
- I am a model.
- Wow!
- I pose and walk in a
straight line for a living.
- What you're going to be helping us with
is posing for a photo shoot,
and how we should pose
and inhabit those K-pop stars.
- Amber's very cool and chill.
- So chill, just like
- Just stand there.
- Hi.
- No, that's, like, awkward.
- What's a very Amber pose to make?
- Um, like a hand in the pocket.
So much going on right now.
- If I model, am I going to be
like one way this way
and another way this way?
This is Keith.
This is Kevin.
(K-pop music playing)
- I am a big fan of Hyuna.
She pulls of like the cute, sexy look.
You're so Hyuna right now.
- Cute and sexy.
- Yes.
- The hardest line to tread. (laughs)
- Exactly.
- I know nothing.
- You sure?
I saw your eyes.
You have, like, the stare.
- Am I doing it?
- She does, like, the head tilt.
So this is like the toothache like,
"My tooth hurts."
That's rap, you're going rap.
- [Kevin] Bro, calm down.
- [Irene] Sexy, sexy.
- [Kevin] There it is.
- [Irene] Yes.
That's really good.
(K-pop music playing)
So Tiffany, I would describe her
as very cute, sweet, and angelic.
- Would you say that I'm the cutest
of the four of us?
- Umm.
- You can say it, it's okay.
This is a safe place.
Kawaii's only, is that only Japan culture?
Or does kawaii transfer?
- Kawaii, Korean is kumi.
- Kumi.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
I think the surprised look.
- It's like a happy surprise.
- Yeah like a happy like (gasps)
- (gasps)
- Yes!
Super kumi.
(K-pop music playing)
For CL, I think something a little bit
more moody, chic, and sexy.
The base of being a
K-pop star is confidence.
- How would you suggest posing
if I was in a photo shoot with you as CL?
- CL's very, like, badass.
She's like the bad girl.
It's more all in the eyes.
You're the queen of K-pop right now.
(K-pop music playing)
- It kind of creates a new perspective
on how we look at K-pop.
Korea itself, the nation itself,
is turning into a brand.
- Aww.
- You like my transformation best?
- Yeah.
- Yeah!
Take that, Zach!
- Come on, come on.
- We don't, yeah we can cut,
I think we're done.